à moins de deux mois du premier tour des
élections municipales les partis
politiques sont en ordre de bataille pas
facile forcément de trouver des
candidats pour c'est un certain c'est
qu'à du front national reçoit sur ce
plateau le président du fn dans le
calvados philippe chapron bonjour vous
serez également ses candidats sur sûre
quand vous mener mais dressé cette liste
du moins on verra puisque vous lancez un
appel quand il est assez difficile de
trouver des candidats bah écoute et oui
c'est difficile c'est un petit peu
difficile effectivement de trouver des
candidats d'ailleurs si on avait voulu
que ce soit facile enfin en tout cas moi
je me serais pas engagé au front
national donc bon difficile nos lits et
certaines de nos listes ont déjà assez
bien avancé d'autres se sont déclarés un
peu sur le tard donc c'est normal qu'on
a eu du mal à trouver des candidats mais
c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
difficile alors vous avez annoncé votre
souhait des présents dans une douzaine
de villes de la région dont six dans le
calvados est-ce que pourriez revoir
votre copie si
le nom pour l'instant de revault qu'une
copie à moi je parle que pour le
calvados à nous avons donc effectivement
en silice dans le calvados nous avons
bon espoir de les constituer d'autant
que bon on n'y est pas encore c'est le
dépôt des listes et début mars et nous
avons encore un petit mois pour nous
consacrer à cela et je profite
d'ailleurs de l'occasion d'être à
l'écran pour faire un appel aux
volontaires et aux patriotes courageux
qui voudraient rejoindre nos listes donc
voilà pourquoi justement les gens
hésitent ou ne se présente cette liste
je crois que bompard le on dit souvent
que le front national est en passe de
dédiabolisation oui c'est vrai en partie
mais lui encore des relents important et
il est vrai qu'il faut reconnaître qu'un
certain nombre de nos amis hésitent à se
projeter sur nos listes part peut-être
difficile de s'afficher le professionnel
pour certains oui je pense et d'ailleurs
on le français est un petit peu grande
gueule on s'appelle on est un petit peu
déçue d'ailleurs de voir que des gens
ont promis leurs engagements et que
d'animaux morts et au moins deux signé
on voit des personnes alors on a
l'impression de revivre ce qui s'est
passé au mandat présidentiel et il
manquait toujours quelques signatures 30
20 10 est ce que ce n'est pas une
technique de communication excusez moi
non mais vous êtes actions n'ont en rien
si vous voulez revenir sur les
présidentielles nous étions
effectivement extrêmement courts et
c'était très chaud à moins donné et
c'est un peu vrai aussi pour les
municipales mais on retrouve un peu le
même phénomène
à savoir que vous savez quand vous allez
voir des gens 6 mois al avance ils ont
toujours le temps et on vous dira que
non quand vous reviendrez ou si vous
aimez mouvement quelques personnes je
suis prêt là c'est le moment est ce que
c'est pas une manière justement de se
victimiser
non absolument pas c'est pas mon style
moi je dis en général la vérité même
toujours et je fais pas de politique
pour baratiner l'objectif l'objectif
c'est d'avoir grandi listes constituées
dans le calvados vision est sûre quand
c'est passé la barre des 10% merci
philippe permettront d'être d'avoir des
élus merci philippe chapron d'avoir
accepté notre invitation